okay for those who are joining this
livestream we are doing ad experimental
ization review there so there are
functions that are tagged in Morphin
language documentation is experimental
and we're trying to figure out whether
we can consider them final whether they
need changes made before their final or
what and we're gonna work through
sequence of different areas so we're
gonna start off with system model ah all
right
boy okay so as Malta here
as Malta here Roger here Malta is here
well then he should say something please
you need to actually say something
hello I'm trying okay and it's Roger
here we need larger Johnson also here
can you hear me now yes we can
where is Roger he needs to be here okay
I don't know tell me what these are
these are not system symbols what are
they race formats um okay but they're
tagged experimental too so this includes
everything system symbols and you know
all pages stacked experimental in that
area okay so my first question is is
anything in the system modular area non
experimental at this time no it's all
experimental okay so it's kind of a big
deal to take it out of what is the state
of enter terrifying things in the system
model of domain its work in progress or
we should have something for twelve one
let's talk about what that design is
because I think that may affect some of
what's going on here I mean so for
example from my point of view let's look
at I mean this is alphabetical order or
not system model itself no I I don't buy
this
where is system model itself system
model itself is experimental here and
you propose to do experimental eyes this
right yes that the idea who there's just
an awful lot of stuff in this um we need
Roger here anyway I'm not going to
discuss this without him this is he
coming we could switch to the second one
till they find Roger let's do that
okay so is Alan here I
I guess not but Francisco is here
perhaps yes yes so the street address
it's being proved a lot with the new
survey which is on its way
when is that supposed to go into
production well we are doing the final
changes in the calculate site so we
should do the test they find out there's
this piece in next week and then they're
planning to go life so we hope before
the conference which I certainly hope so
yeah I should hope so
um and hopefully we'll be able to show
some additional functionality there
right made possible at the new geo
server right so the idea is that with
the new user will be able to expand the
IDs first we are improving their current
ones like for example these three others
okay so look I'm not sure I buy this
because I think that this is really a
street address location right because
it's going to return a geo position I
would expect that in the interpreter
that says called street address would
return some kind of canonicalized street
address you know what I'm saying
all right that was an excursion we had
known time ago having this more
computable way of expressing artists
which right now so I mean to me this
probably should be a function geo
address or something that is the analog
of geolocation but a symbolic
representation of an address am I making
sense
as an association and to my mind
something called street addressed should
return one of those and perhaps this
should be street addressed location
I'm a making sense
yes I will agree but well for now that
we don't have yet any street address
canonical form I'm aware of that so the
question is I think we should keep this
experimental and I think what we should
plan on doing I think we could introduce
the street address location right
and we could I mean for now this could
go on returning geolocation but in the
end street address location should
return the geolocation and Street
addressed should return a geo address
object ok ok so now we will experiment
doesn't know we can do that change yeah
but I think we might as well introduce a
street address location and start moving
code over to use that am I making sense
I mean it's even arguable it should be
called address no I think no street
address location is ok or um yeah now I
mean in terms of the the geo address
have we already designed this ok so I
mean I think it should be you know
whatever the thing is you know city you
know a DM you know administrative
division city whatever it is right so it
should be something that looks more or
less like this and I think given the new
geo server with its new geocoding
capabilities we should start actually
building geo addresses
okay
okay okay I was talking also with Kosair
to see how we can design this fine I
mean I think fundamentally this is what
it should be roughly like is a you know
it should have certain elements here you
know it's fundamentally a hierarchical
specification where these are I mean you
know um street number or something I
don't know what it's called but you know
in the end it gets down to street number
ten or whatever else um sometimes those
get funky because they can be I'm sorry
Stephanie yeah I'm sorry who what event
Devon three yeah oh you're still waiting
for your area sorry okay sorry
um right and obviously all the elements
should be in general optional because
right right but I mean I think that the
you know this should be an entity the
street name itself
I guess should be an entity although
that is you know that's complicated
because you know that means we're naming
every street in the world um you know
we're turning into an entity every
street in the world but we have enough
data to do that right for cities we
don't have all the cities because
sometimes they are not considered City
but probably for the address point of
view it's a city well fine okay fine I'm
saying this is something we need to
develop okay so this is a um okay
but anyway so please introduce street
address location will leave street
address for the time being
maybe we don't even need to documents
redressed location yet although we could
um and you know I would say you could
make street address location to make it
not experimental because I think that
one is is going to be just fine I'm
making sense right well
yes I think so even when it would be
nice if this is three thousand
celebration will also eat these few
others to come deposition well no sorry
that that should be the task for your
position itself yeah I think so it and
no doubt geo address can cash a geo
position inside it
sure that will be another element right
okay do we have Roger for the system
model discussion he isn't we weren't
able to find him yet there isn't Onix
I'm gonna move on to Alex I'm not going
to do it without Roger okay okay so
thank you for Francisco if that's that's
all for you you can disappear yes that's
all for him okay thanks thanks a lot
okay asymptotics we could see Roger for
this one as well
actually George just left but I the key
point is it a mission over there that
Roger would like this to be done as part
of the asymptotics review for 12.1 and
because we have few more functions
coming in over there but they already
for what so why is it in the Mason all
right because I mentioned to rod that we
are able to since we the ask yes or no
the answer is yes we do want to finalize
them but it would be better to them as
part of the channel as introducing new
for 12.1 and they all kind of ready to
go there's only one design change which
we need but which is that that design
changes that we have this new thing
called asymptotic and we would like to
use a limit like notation in addition to
what we are allowing now because we want
the leading asymptotic for something
let's say and what's it called
asymptotic yes that doesn't sound like a
good name yeah week so but that's part
of the larger thing for 12.1 so I write
that we could actually basically delay
that which will happen very soon we have
we ready to discuss that as well all
right okay then let's not do that here
okay so okay well I guess you're all
folk thank you okay
okay so we ready with them Jason and
Michael Michael won't be able to attend
but Jason is here okay listen listen
this is the first in the series of
meetings I don't want any I'm not doing
these meetings without you know we can
try and do this with Jason but if we get
stuck it's gonna wait until Michael is
around okay I mean I did check with
Michael he said it was fine to go ahead
with Jason I never get I don't care I
insist on having the senior people
involved in each of these areas here
okay
otherwise we're just gonna get things
messed up and we're gonna get you know
oh but I didn't mention this or that
okay okay all right I don't understand
how we cannot be the experimental izing
Adam but we are the experimental izing
all the attributes of Adam that just
seems wrong to me but Jason can you
speak to this yes so sorry I'm very new
to what the experiments lysing something
is so so I mix it to it for the rest of
your life right okay so Adam everything
that we've the data the syntax we've
documented so far will that we would
obviously continue to accept as I use it
I sometimes want to add in maybe an
additional syntax and additional well
the properties let's talk about that
okay um well I mean okay but so you
believe that the system as a whole is
working decently well yeah yeah but I
haven't gotten a lot of feedback from
users yet and so I kind of want to in
general that's my idea that I want to to
get more feedback before then from them
before D experimental izing like
molecule or molecule pattern boys anyway
say there's no point in not the
experimental icing if we do experimental
icing a bunch of these other things
there's no way I mean it's crazy to the
experimental eyes some tentacle function
that depends on molecule while not the
experimental icing molecule itself sorry
that just doesn't make sense okay okay
they here's a question so I was reading
science magazine which I don't do very
often but anyway there's an article in
it about the some
well not shaped molecules made of carbon
okay it's a carbon nano torus here so my
question is can we can we represent
these things we should be able to right
yeah so so if they can be represented by
a connection table than we can
generating the coordinates for those
more intricate and convoluted molecules
would be is much trickier yes yeah well
okay but let's talk about what you want
to do with atom I mean I answer is we're
not going to do experimental eyes
tentacle functions without the
experimental eyes in the core function
and if you don't feel ready to the
experimental eyes the core function
we're not gonna do it for this version
okay so yeah I mean just in general I do
feel that it could use some time and
some feedback okay well tell me what so
for example for Adam tell me what the
things that you think should be changed
or cuz we've changed on let's see so
users I've had a specific request to
have a Adam level meta information so
that's simple like we could just add a
about what so you could put in what the
source was what the name was
from the whatever file that you brought
it in from this we don't think this is
in the name value this is some other
thing for the name value sequence is
that correct yes by the way this is
wrong if this this should say comma dot
dot here if that's what it means is that
what it means not just dot dot dot there
that is exactly what it means I can
please fix um okay okay so you're saying
putting in meta information there that
right yes
okay so
these are properties that we're
supporting right now a formal charge
mass number unpaired electron count so
other additional things that people want
so you could we're interested in being
able to do constrained embedding when
you create a larger molecule but you
want to give coordinates to a small
subset of them and then and then we
would generate the rest with with the
caveat that the the specified ones match
up and so that's something you could add
at the at this level of the expression
right right so so you have a large
molecule that has a little benzene ring
then you specifically want that benzene
ring to be in the XY plane at the origin
so you you specify the coordinates of
some of the atoms so okay so you're
saying that you would put coordinate
things into the the properties of them
right the user could specify it and then
when you create the molecule you you
parse that and generate the coordinates
at that time okay so I mean you should
probably let's get a drop spec for that
it sounds reasonable to me
um okay all right what what is just just
for my information what's the current
frontier of what you're doing with all
this molecule stuff guys what I'm doing
for I'm looking at molecule fingerprints
so this is something that that I'd
really like to to flesh out and bring
for the next version what does that mean
so molecule fingerprints you you take
the molecule and you create a bit vector
of 2048 for example ones and zeros that
are I that are constructed in many
different ways and then those can be
used either for substructure screening
or mature comparison similarity
comparisons or for machine learning
purposes okay so this is a net encoder
for molecules basically well hash them
but it it is and it has if there are a
few extra caveats one that's very
interesting that um there are these
types of fingerprints called pattern
fingerprints where
if you have a substructure any bits that
are turned on in the substructure will
be turned on in the molecules
fingerprint right so the right that's a
hierarchical hash code of some kind
which and people have hooked this up to
two databases to a PostgreSQL type of
thing to make for fast substructure
searches okay that's interesting
all right we're probably gonna have
molecule fingerprint or some such other
thing as a function yes which will have
various different kinds of fingerprint
things which will return some kind of
vector and we might need to have some
molecule fingerprinting function that
you would then in order to generate them
but that's we saw what I just said so I
just said a molecule fingerprint
function writes the fingerprints right
yes yes that's extremely similar to the
feature extract but it has some of the
same issues of forward compatibility
that feature extract has yes I imagine
might even be a version of feature
extract might be that you want to put it
in for it's not quite feature extract
but it's it's some yeah anyway okay fine
all right so I don't think we do
experimental eyes for right now expect
to do that in the next version okay okay
all right what's next here we can switch
to resource system um and I just got in
touch with Roger he's joining in a
couple of minutes so hopefully by the
time we are done with resources to meet
Johnson okay and is he near you no okay
fine all right
so who's who's here representing this
Bob and Rita Bob I'm here Bradley
Bradley you me sorry yep Bradley okay so
which things here have already been do
you experimental eyes resource object
and all those guys already at the
experimental eyes right right
you know what design resource define
resource function does it's a simple
constructor function that if you don't
care about documentation examples is an
alternative to the definitional book
just as it shows right there why is this
the correct way around
you mean the input order yeah why's why
is the name of a function second you
know choose smartly I see so there's a
one argument form which which typically
makes sense right all right okay I don't
have an objection to that resource
function well this is this is the main
the main thing that's took off for 12
people using I think there's good yeah I
think it's all fine now one question
that I have is the return value of an
unavailing resource function right we
want to have formatting rules in place
okay we can do that yeah fine please do
yeah okay
I think we might need a way to let
people down in certain cases my default
it could be I think the standard form
for the thing should be I mean the input
form can show you what was then
underneath yeah but the standard form
should just be a nice gray blob
right yeah yeah yeah if it's just for
men girls actually preserve what you
hear hi um yeah I mean it should come
back looking like that in the case where
the thing is is fed garbage right yeah
a number of them it is good but how come
some of them usually and well anything
anything that has an operator for
musha's what does almost certainly has
the formatting rules because that would
look like garbage otherwise otherwise
for now it's been the by default there
okay so don't do that
yeah yeah we passed that ASAP and
Patrick update it because I think that
will be a really desirable thing to get
fixed
sure okay fine let's make it happen okay
now let's look at these other ones here
okay so resource register why is that
not ready to the experimental eyes so we
talked about those resource system path
thing that we want to put in hi on my
to-do list it will be integral to this
function and we don't really have a
design for what elements were going to
allow on that path I see so this is a
resource system where you're saying it
can be my public cloud resource system
and my private cloud resource system is
that right
right order me Yeah right or this can
research where research registers I'm
talking about the pod thing which is
necessary right where to look for
resource objects exactly so it could be
multiple resource systems it could be
you know if you could take a stream like
local which means look for lovely cache
and the order of it matters
so you might just be rearranging things
that are already there it's like the
persistence path in fact I think you
should take the same without proceeding
locations as values
it should take morels but maybe only
with a URL wrapper you know we sorta
have to figure out those details of the
design path and I don't want to be
experimental eyes this until we do fine
well can you get that on the agenda soon
because I can't imagine it's gonna be
that difficult to make this resource
pause I mean it presumably should be
called resource pause okay fine so too
tall a resource system pause Brandon the
option is resource system pause yes I
think the only thing that needs to clear
some of it is URLs and some of it is um
persistence locations right right but
yeah yeah never talk to might fall into
that system servers designed as well and
they could how to interpret a naked
string there might be a vacuity x' if
you wrap everything in something like
URL or cloud object or filed it why
don't you get it built with that
assumption and then we'll worry about
the naked strings later yeah okay um by
the way and resource register I would I
would recommend that well I assume I
mean that can be referenced by name I
mean I would just have resource register
of quotes name as that as the next line
here rather than having that have to I
mean we don't usually do that where we
explained that there are multiple
possibilities all in one line it's it's
not terrible um okay
resource submit
right now this is typically used without
knowing it from the definition of right
it's called underneath from a button
this is a programmatic way to do it and
you open this you have the two argument
form for an update I don't know I guess
it's fine I'm not the best possibility
I don't know nobody's really using it so
I didn't think it was really worth the
experiments wiser well we've talked
about exposing versioning a bit more so
now I don't think this is ready to the
expose yeah resource update that
something people should be using right I
mean I've gotten you know messed up a
few times because there is a more recent
version of a resource but I didn't get
it right so right now that I mean if all
we wanted was a dummy form where use
resource update gets the latest one it
would be good to go but we want to
specify a version we expect out a design
for that week ago so you know that's ok
but I have a question here I mean in
what is the messaging so I'm using a
function there's a more recent version
how does it message me right so
typically it will happen the first time
you invoke that resource in a new
session after an update has been
published and it'll give you a message
there's a more recent function use
resource update to get it and then
there's also this button in the message
I don't particularly like but it works
dude can you show it to me or is it not
I haven't seen that one yet I sorry I'm
like a development branch checked out on
this particular issue and it would
probably be bad if I try ok fine fine
but that's something we have to look at
I think that make sense yeah but but we
it needs to allow a version
specification where there's an option
the dollar publisher ID actually just
last Thursday I committed to change that
needs to be done so I think I just need
to update some aggregation and we should
be able to do those are we sure that
correct they're pretty simple that we
can determine the right well I mean the
main issue is the main issue is that the
we want to have this idea that by
default people are publishing with their
own names so to speak right and only if
they want to they all can be under you
know the octopus lab or something
whatever it is right yes so it but yeah
and then 12 $1 publisher ID if you just
evaluated it'll call the resources them
assuming your cloud-connected get your
default publisher ID and show it to you
in 12 zero it just returns in death this
is the change I just committed on
Thursday okay so we needed I need to
document that still the changes in 12
one probably today's build advice
they've got a publisher ID equals you
know pink elephant or something right
that's that's the only way to do it so
yeah that that then when you use
research submit it will attempt to
submit it as pink elephant they'll check
that your cloud-connected wolfram ID and
if so submitted okay and that only
persists over the session so I'm I
thought for like how you set your
default it would be through like a web
interface like well you should change
cloud preferences we could have the same
thing for restore system fine but then
that's so that's a thing in the cloud
account
yeah by the way I'd like to say and it's
related to the system service issue that
anything you can set in the GUI for the
cloud account you should be able to set
programmatically okay I have not had
those conversations with cloud just yes
but I'll make sure that right I mean
it's similar to set options of dollar
front-end
but you know I think we need a general
way to do that and we might need a way I
mean we may even need a way to do that
for external entities like the things
that come up in the open application
server stack okay all right now resource
remove I think I should be deprecated we
have to lead object it's more general
and it doesn't simply alright so if we
think that's the case why don't we
proceed to deprecated resource remove do
we do we need any sort of functionality
for unregistering something without
deleting it or is that just not there's
an thought for that there there's a tool
for doing that resource on registrar's
but yeah and I don't think resource
remove is the right symbol for it anyway
right we can we can revisit that I don't
yeah okay why did we did we mentioned it
changed significantly in 1208 returns to
data set a list of objects but yeah I
think that sort of has the same
resources the past thing you know not
research it could be the experimental
eyes because the path is just sort of an
extension that wouldn't break anything
but it's an important extension so I
don't know how we handle that as far as
experimental tag um I think we could do
exponent Eliza good in that right yeah
it's an important feature but it won't
break anything
because it'll be in like a method option
or let's take exponent allows reso such
it seems either I don't see a problem
with research right now just looking
through this documentation
the little come there in the second
table methods are not links which the
very less table columns should be yeah
and the values of the strings in the
second table aren't clearly right so
like that objects will give you the pre
12-0 form of research where it gives a
list of resource objects was my list one
cool just list yeah I think we came up
with this in the yes we don't want to
mess with it if that's what such
consistency implies I mean maybe a bunch
of resource objects that's this case but
like in text search they could use the
same thing and it would be content
objects web search same thing whatever
their objects are okay okay yeah I think
we could yeah I'll template those
options and we can be experimental eyes
okay all right fine so we are or not the
experimental Ising dollar publisher ID
yeah I think we can I mean there
documentation changes I need to make so
I wish I mean they will be in for twelve
one I don't know what the proper process
is if I should make sure those are in
before I click the button or I can click
the button and then do that
documentation I think you can click the
button I mean once we're not once we
clear the design isn't going to change
I'm a little bit nervous about publisher
ID and dollar polish ready why don't you
leave an expert I'm in nobody nobody's
using them because nobody external has
more than one so it's not terribly
important right okay it's a question for
our live stream from sander asking about
will there be a session on function
repository reviews were the possibility
of taking popular function repository
functions and adding
the core language the answer is yes we
intend to do that we don't have that
trial yet and I don't know whether we
yet have a process for it in terms of
surfacing you know our favorite or most
used functions I think it's really a
question can you guys guys comment on
that or is that for other people we
could use but we don't have anything no
I understand it I mean it will be
interesting for us for you guys to try
and surface the top 20 things that you
think might be put in the language yeah
that'd be cool I'm sure I think they
will be very useful to do that I mean
there'll be a trade-off because there'll
be ones where could we got a bunch of
background noise here um that there'll
be ones where it's very straightforward
to put them in the language and they're
ones but but it isn't all that important
and the ones where it's quite difficult
but where it is more important right and
you know for putting an external for
anything in the function repository we
don't care that the code is perfectly
efficient it doesn't need to be optimal
but there need to be an actual review of
the code possibly a full-scale rewriting
function is design is good with
implementations there yep so it's tricky
yep but I mean I think we should at
least get a top a list of top candidates
yeah yeah okay okay please do
all right why is there are ways until I
can anka of how these functions are
doing in terms because there were
hopefully we will get a ranking of that
but there will be some confounding
factors like how long ago was it
introduced you know what was it
advertised in a particular place I think
there will be some very fine details
that could affect you know usage
patterns in ways that aren't informative
like for example a function could be
widely used inside another function
that is the real design thing that
anybody cares about but the thing on the
inside could nevertheless be called
every time that function is called just
because that was conveniently how that
function was written in fact in fact the
top the top usage one is the exact case
what is it oh it's like internal
blockers or inherited black something
that you know what is it general
utilities things that's been around for
a while that is now in the function
repository and there's three or four
functions that in there function of
Australia that also use it so I I think
it's most most of its uses come from
that's okay though I mean it is straight
topless anyway yeah no but it might be
that the factoring but anyway it's some
by the way I don't even know what's
happened to the you know additional
content acquisition from our various
obvious my novel sources yeah are you
sure are you sure because I mean there
should be a list of sources of content
and like I know you haven't mind the nks
I mean that the stuff you've mined the
stuff that's already been documented
right no single thing come through that
we can take a look at that list it was
something that Sushma had put together
and I don't think she's had a chance to
revisit in a while so there hasn't been
like we should continue pushing as much
focus on that since she moved yeah yeah
we shouldn't talk too much about okay
fine but I'm saying can you please bring
that up again in the next meeting we
have but motion repository yeah by the
way probably at the point where we could
live stream some function repository
meetings has some appropriate okay um
been on the livestream it seems like
most in the repository right now a staff
created wonderful outside creators will
get credit absolutely they get credit
though
yes many some people on the stream I
think have contributed like I think
Sanders country to quite a few things um
okay I think we don't know what percent
is it's certainly more than ten less
than 50 that's an external yeah I mean
that's probably the similar to what
happened demonstrations budget where
it's now you know 98 percent or
something or ninety you know external
but it just takes a while to get that
started a lot of content we we want to
put in there anyway we've been looking
for a good way to release it so Ark
count is gonna be increasing for a while
still right and you know for people on
the livestream contribute to the
function repository okay let's let's go
back here yep thank you very much
that's tourmalet okay so this is a big
hairy piece of design what do we know
about how people have been using this
Roger and multi I mean we we have heard
feedback and I would say it's mostly
positive and nothing major like if there
are some some users have found minor
bugs but none has come back that is
actually a showstopper or anything that
actually changes the design so I mean
one issue which continues to my god this
is so complicated
so what has happened to the entity a
vacation of these things I mean we had a
meeting like two or three weeks ago and
we discussed a bunch of avenues one of
them was having an entity store which is
basically a way to access the system
models which we've been working on
that's the part that we should have for
it well one I mean there's already a
pretty much a pretty close version in
12-0 but it's very undocumented for it
well one it should be cleaner and
probably have its own entity
documentation page one would assume so
why is the four system model why does it
exist why is that not just an entity
with with entity um well just for
starters if you scroll down to the first
example it should exemplify why you want
something nicely types it you can
clearly see what it is well in an entity
you just get a name well I mean that's
not necessarily Churov entities but I
understand that point you could make net
model is another example where you
actually getting well net models are not
entities right now models are coming
from so what's the relationship between
the resource system and system models
this discussion again we want in the
future to be able to distribute examples
of system models and entities and
research system oh we haven't gotten
there yet okay but so why is it not the
case that every system model is
basically a resource object yeah why
would it be because the convenient way
to document it's a convenient framework
to you know I mean we have a full
library I mean every system are first of
all
more components which makes no sense on
their own like a resistor fine you know
or an inductor okay a circuit is
something that's fully put together
whereas a where the resistor an inductor
is not an out of the 6,000 objects in a
standard library the vast majority are
just components like that they're not
fully configured systems I understand
that understand that so okay look look
we've got two frameworks that exist in
the system one is entity stores the
other is resource the resources but I
thought entity stores was kind of you
know an extensibility mechanism it
wasn't itself German saying we don't
ship entity stores we ship entities that
is correct
and she's implemented conceptually using
entity stores although they're not all
done that way internally right but then
the source is itself
kind of like you know the current
extension mechanism for ends right yeah
yeah yeah right for entities now that is
right now the resource system is larger
scale so for example a whole entity
store can live in the resource system
right now the question here is what's
the grin
molarity of these things and toward
aslam in the resource system has the
feature that the typical but but also I
mean over meta Pro amines so first of
all the naming schemes gonna be very
long a hierarchical in entities um
because it needs to fit in with the rest
of them right but also my intake on
entities is that they're fairly is sort
of fixed they're not open-ended they're
it's true yeah you know the the the
fundamental thing about the modeling
system is that it's open-ended it's like
chemistry it's like you know it's well
it's it's even more open-ended in
chemistry because truly you build new
ones all the time rather let's look at
that analogy for a second then because
in chemistry we decided not to make so
in chemistry what happens is there are
named molecules there are entities right
but the representation of a general
molecule is not an entity right right so
we have the exact same thing here
good ok so what you're saying is there
are named complete systems which are
entities although I think components
could particularly entities as well yes
I mean what we discussed in the entity
focused meeting a few weeks ago was that
the entity store we will ship with
together with this will be a way to
represent I mean you can access all of
these system models through the entity
store which allows you to do some neat
things like navigating the hierarchy of
models which is not as natural through
system model properties but in the end
you still have a system model as an
object that you can extract from the
entity store um in a similar way that I
guess you can extract molecules as a
molecule object from from that and T
store or entity I don't know if it's a
store but yeah sorry sir
again you can extract no but molecule
properties are from the molecule object
so the situation there is we have
molecule entities which are a bunch of
named molecules okay we have a molecule
object which is an extensible you know
it's more like an integer rather than a
name you know it's not like with
integers we don't have named integers we
just have you know the integer integer
structure right right so the analogue on
in this area would be that we have an
entity store with named entities with
the things we ship with the product like
the standard library which includes both
components and fully simulated Bowl
systems and then you have the analog to
the molecule object which is system
model which is also you can build your
own system model objects so it's nice
you so then it's like net model or like
um
or like molecule yes exactly
all right so let's just understand that
full analogy okay so I mean what
difference you have is you have a
hierarchical component names yes I don't
really understand how that maps into
everything else
but I'm not sure there is a direct
analogy to all the kills or not models
probably not well okay so you've got to
think there are other things going on
where we this is that hierarchy is kind
of important from Metallica
compatibility perspective but it's a
little bit like there are other ways to
name things that are existing other
databases and we have some alignment
between entities that you have different
ways of giving can I ask what's happened
to our effort to have a standardized
browser for entities or resource objects
and to get rid of the system model
examples function what's happened to
that you guys were going to be working
on that with other people weren't you
but we weren't the ones driving it it
was it was you brought up a bunch of
things that needed to be there which had
nothing to do with us but that was okay
so I think Sushma might have been given
that project but since she's now been
reassigned something may have happened
to that project we need to bring that
project back to life again who here can
can make sure that that Sushma is aware
of this you may in fact be the one
getting this project yeah that's that's
okay then you need to bring it back to
life again by the way what's happened to
the this the monitoring project
standardization of monitoring indicators
what do you mean
like loading things yeah yeah I mean the
progress indicators yes yeah that's
that's been ongoing okay all right fine
so we'll see something for 12
for that right yes okay so let's come
back to this I feel like I don't think
it's a great idea to do experimental
eyes these things yet um
it seems like we're having the exact
same discussion like we did for 12-0
yeah well I think we're gonna go on
having that until we start seeing all
these pieces come together because I'm
worried that we're going to figure out
that something doesn't really work
between I mean we've got n cities
resource or esource system presumably
you could have a little entity store in
the resource system of probably in the
data repository for right now of
components basically let's say that you
wanted to do some different kind of I
don't know thing for you know
optoelectronics or something right right
and this typically they're called
modeling libraries in this area and
that's typical typical thing you ship
like this is my library of opto whatever
okay so question now is that fit into
the rubric of our data repository if if
somebody wants to do that has it fit
into the data repository no no the Dean
well we can make something fit but but
let's let me just describe what it is
first of all so so a library is the
thing that we haven't gotten to yet
function repository is sort of a single
function but we haven't gotten to the
libraries of functions yet and typically
when you model for instance hmm let's
say that you want to let's say you pick
a domain like the electrical domain then
you you need a bunch of components you
need a bunch of ways to connect them
yeah then and you need to sort of
correctly model that so you need a whole
kit of things so you can't really model
anything I understand that but I don't
think oh yeah right but I mean to me
this is like a bag of entities more than
it is a bag of functions it's not so
much a bag as a very carefully
constructed or whatever I mean it's it's
but I mean do you think this particular
area of physics is like a bag of
entities
some yeah I mean but that's kind of what
they model on and a domain of
engineering a domain of physics and if
you call X with system model is that it
isn't modeling I mean the thing that I
still bugs me is the disconnect between
essentially systems of Odie's which is
what system model is doing and all the
stuff we have now with finite elements
and PDEs I don't know okay that's a
whole different let me then address that
so first of all you need das a little
bit more general than okay I understand
that yes okay right okay so but there is
this disconnect you know so you can
model an awful lot of things with Odie's
or das
including things that you would normally
think that you need to use pd's for you
know by using an a what the hell are
they called then basically with a big
system of Odie's where you build a
compartment for each like thermal for
instance you know okay well okay the
fact that there's some way of
simplifying it like that is is you know
it's all not always going to work I mean
if you're trying to do finite element
analysis of some complicated shape
you're not going to be able to decompose
that into a bunch of compound right but
but you can't use finite element is
useless for control for instance the
signal processing so it's the question
of what is your goal why is it useless
for control why can't it be in the loop
for control because it can but it's
exceptionally rare at this point you
know it's a fraction of a fraction of a
percent that understand that's not yet
here but right it's more realistic it's
something like a machine learning thing
I mean like for example could you have
you know let's say that you wanted a
donkey in the you know in the loop in
this thing right you're gonna make a
model of a donkey and you know your
model well I and it's bad example good
example you know maybe there's some
differential equation model of a donkey
but maybe more plausibly that's not like
a donkey let's pick a sea anenome okay
well whatever
a starfish I don't care some weird
creature right okay it does various
things let's imagine that you had a
machine learning model of the starfish
you didn't have a you know mechanical
model of the starfish that you made with
the Odie's and things or daes or
whatever right so my question then is
could one of these boxes be a machine
learning black box well we're working on
that now okay so so the answer is yes
well soon
but then what that would be is
presumably that will be a net model
embedded in a system model that's right
yes okay but it need to be exported you
know through onyx and so on and so that
export is not quite there yet
it's a release or two away um yeah I get
that I mean so my question here is okay
um I mean I I'm but this is you know if
you're gonna model behavior even for for
it's always a question of what is your
goal with them all I know okay and if
you if your goal with a model is for
instance for for technical systems these
kinds of models are excellent for
control signal processing and even
simulating behavior they're very precise
now for some things you use PDEs instead
or what's called difficult
compartmentalized models versus
distributed models PD is like a
distributed model whereas this a
compartmental okay let's go for example
take another example of traffic jam
modeling okay yeah you know one of the
popular models is some random cellular
automata Marvel okay but that's yet
another sort of at you know style of of
modeling I guess
I get it I mean this big project that we
can't talk about quite right here but
but the you know for a customer on on
traffic modeling mmm is you know I don't
know whether you've paid attention or
know what's been done there you might
find it interesting because that is a
whole different set of issues that come
up of ways to do modeling
that's a combination of agent based and
this and that but that's why I'm
bringing it up you kind of need to
qualify what you say when you say
modeling because many people say
modeling and they mean their thing and
their thing might be one of ten major
things so if you talk to a guy in a cat
industry when they say simulating they
always means you build a PDE and you use
finite elements cuz that's the weight I
think oh the problem that I have with
this is we have this very general named
system model hmm okay but in a sense
it's a mop what will be the fully
qualified version of the name system
model system model no no no the fully
qualified name as in you're explaining
why it's not a model why it's not a PDE
it's not a cellular automaton it's not
an agent-based model it is what what
kinds of systems does it deal with what
they're like a model no that's not going
to cut it no but what is the modified
what it is well okay fine what is the
generic fully qualified the non-branded
fully qualified version of what it is
[Music]
the I don't know
there is a name like that okay because
it it's it's not just in the end it does
deal with event models but not as fully
as your traffic model which probably is
is very event oriented sort of ground up
that's what it's optimized for okay my
events in system modeler
okay my question is look at some point
in the future okay so like an
agent-based model for example is there a
way that the current framework of system
model and all of these different options
and all these different things here
right could in principle be applied to
an agent-based model or is it just
totally hopeless and these are just
specifically things for essentially dæ
models that's it that's sort of a quest
how far does the Metallica language
extend in a way well but you're telling
me it's da es right it's systems of daes
right that's and the things that clearly
cannot be modeler goes yes yeah but I
mean okay because I want to sell it
automaton in the loop can I have it or
can I not have it does it funny
in the general case Metallica is a see
interface you can have whatever you want
well but does that work with what we
have here yeah okay
your face is gonna be okay I know it's
not gonna go into this why wouldn't we
be able to have I mean you're talking
about putting machine learning stuff
inside these models why wouldn't you be
able to have a PD stuff inside these
models I mean look at that too
but and but the interface to it is gonna
be kind of black box ish right yeah um
it's largely gonna say how does it
communicate with the rest of the system
sure you know that's you know
laura-leigh what goes on inside of it
you don't know about you don't okay but
but fundamentally what you're telling me
is the you know the thing has a finite
number of tentacles everything every
component has a finite number of
tentacles a finite number of variables
that are relevant I mean till so for
example I was just talking to somebody
about old mr. Babbage's mechanical
notation okay which was an attempt to so
he had things he called I think train
diagrams which were how how is something
connected to something else and he had
what they called unit diagrams I think
which was some kind of timing diagrams
about how things worked
what is the modern analog of that those
are called them so you do it when you do
for instance relay ladder logic and
other things those are usually call I
think events diagrams because yes
primarily he doesn't really model the
continuous movement of them he's
primarily focused on events is this make
sure
this finishes before the next thing ya
know and you have similar kind of
sequencing things going on you know it's
sort of a macro level so at the macro
level model which doesn't model the the
detailed behavior necessarily anything
it's just a modeler there is something a
little bit like that they called them
state graphs okay
so what is the relationship of this this
thing what's it called ladder logic or
something which is the thing used yeah
that's what I was saying ladder logic
but so and am i right in saying that you
know when you program a robot with like
PLC type whatever that call is that I
using the right terms that the dead
reckoning robots how do you program
those what's that what's a dead
reckoning robots why I don't know I'm
using that term I mean a robot which
just does one thing right you know put
this bolt and move it move the arm of
the robot in this way to put so now I
mean you rarely rarely you said I don't
know exactly what the best current
interfaces to robot programming but it
used to be that you have to give a
sequence of paths that it follows and
those are relatively simplistic paths um
okay
but so explain to me I mean ladder logic
is a subset of what system modular deals
with is that correct yes you know state
graphs generalizes that so ladder logic
was literally invented for relays
telecom switches and things like that
okay although I was called in at once
you know to to revise a nuclear power
plant where they were concerned with
correctness of this thing you could
imagine always a good idea yeah yeah you
know should this pump actually always
work for instance uh-huh would be a good
thing or should help us be able to deal
with this represented originally in
ladder logic exactly the whole design
was done in ladder logic and so that I
bet if you pick a random nuclear plant
here today in the US
they've probably had their documentation
in ladder logic cuz they're from the
seventies but so the representation of
that as a kind of simplistic programming
so the modern modern version of that
Stephan kind of got inspired by there's
an academic version of that that was
developed for concurrent programming
called Petri nets and the industrial
version of that are called
graph set or diversion in system modeler
were in Metallica is called state graphs
and they deal with concurrent events
secure and chill events branching and so
on okay so that's interesting so Petri
Nets I mean isn't Michael trout working
on Petri Nets in connection with some
something about food recipes I have no
idea I think so I mean it wouldn't be
unreasonable because it's because that's
kind of what they use they're used as
for so you can imagine that you're gonna
do recipe following for a chemical plant
yeah well that sounds pretty much like
cooking to me so you know heat this
vessel up to a certain degree stir it
you know and insert this other
ingredients okay so what's the
relationship then between patients and
and so are also assembly plants like a
car assembly plant you know so at that
macro level you view a robot as a black
box do your thing and when you're done
tell me then we start in with the next
thing and that's my operating system
work to which I'm saying you do this
process when you're done tell me then
duties parallel if we were going to have
a general representation of Petri Nets
for instance but Petri Nets have the
unfortunate thing of being in general on
analyzable
on because they've unbounded state so
the industrial version doesn't have that
how does it work
it as typically you know finite but it
has timers and other things which is
also very practical in and beautiful
what's it called again the industrial
one and so there's a standard as a
European standard that's called graph
set which is the French name and
the German names called sequential
function charts and a standard version
of it in Metallica is called state
graphs boy I do not know all the stuff
okay so that's um so we should
understand this before Michael goes on
from it because at the macro level so
you could imagine you know at the macro
level even for a car there are things
that needs to be sequenced you know and
for an airplane you know like a landing
if you're gonna go in for landing
there's a certain sequence of things you
need to do and validate and be sure
right or a start for takeoff I guess
it's good right that's typical what
happens in other industrial settings -
like you're gonna start up I was looking
at I wasn't abb once okay and they built
this giant fluidized fluidized
combustion coal bed which made a plasma
like thing out of coal powder it was
very efficient way of governing coal but
could you imagine how many pumps and
valves and other things that needs to be
sort of sequenced and initialized to
just start one of those things or
recover from a failure and it was
literally like a binder full of these
diagrams okay but so you're saying that
nowadays these could be implemented as
state graphs for system model yes right
yeah and there's something that's used
for software systems that's not
unrelated to that which are called UML
diagrams right okay and there's a sub
part of that called sis ml which is UML
for systems so I mean UML is yet another
one of these things which we've looked
at implementing at various times and
decided we don't care well an UML was
derived from basically an Israeli guy
designing hierarchical finite state
machines called state charts um and it
was
originally motivated from a fighter
project as you could imagine in Israel
that's that's its origin mm-hmm so yes
there is a lot of languages for modeling
um and these these slightly simpler
things like state machines and so on or
you know there's particularly many
formalisms for that but so okay so we've
got finite automata we've got Petri Nets
I mean those are the two kind of math Li
versions of that type of stuff kind of
and we don't yet have a standardized
final otamatone system no and again in
this context and the finite automata is
commonly described in this the best many
use cases for that alone but the one
that's useful in the context of systems
would be like a more mealy machine not
just the autonomous a transducer of some
kind right so it feels to me like we
need a more general story here I mean
that system model is I think that it's
you know I think that that the space of
problems that this addresses is I'm not
saying it can't be extended but I think
it sort of hits the the use case is
pretty well um mm-hmm
well okay but but still look Roger this
is the the ante you know what you're
saying is system model hits a bunch of
popular use cases what I'm now
complaining about is what's the general
framework that it lives in right because
it could be that if we generalize this
framework a bit that we use the
machinery of system model to implement a
bunch of this as a kind of a it's a
trivial you know
and what system model does but
nevertheless those things might actually
be quite useful although I know but it
needs to be for that to be useful that
it needs to integrate with and we do
extend the range of system alerts you
know always there's always those
extensions going on and a lot of it can
be in fact implemented as new libraries
is what I'm saying let's say that you
wanted some particular finite automata
some other variant of finite automata
yeah it can be typically modeled and
implemented as an extension as a library
I understand but that's not how you'd
want to do it I mean that you know some
some complicated reach ability thing for
a Petri net or for some some kind of you
know finite state machine you know state
minimization right we never can
implement that as a function for general
system model because it won't work right
but state minimization for example is
something that we could very well want
as a function for finite automata and
just saying oh you can make it a library
of system model you will now put that in
there I mean there's a value no I I
don't disagree but I don't think that
this is it's it's there's a lot of
things that one can do for it let's take
an example of something that is in there
okay like block diagrams yeah okay so
the most common case of block diagrams
basically correspond to constant
coefficient systems of differential
equations or difference equations okay
that's exactly our state space model
object in Mathematica okay or transfer
function model object those two sort of
different ways of saying the same thing
and now there's a ton of things that you
can do to manipulate those systems in
fact we have whole subsystems that do
that in Mathematica like for control
design or observer design oh yeah but
but
for example in other words the system
modeler doesn't do that system modelers
job in life is to simulate it it's the
primary primary job so for example you
know I'm a sometime consumer of finite
automata right but my use case for
finite automata is absolutely not
captured by all these things you know my
use cases though III realize that you
know but I think that we need a more
extensive kind of support for finite
automata in dices in in Wolfram language
yeah I know is it's a different thing
it's closer to graph in spirit and then
sister all right but I mean if we look
at this complete picture from ladder
logic to all this state graph stuff and
so on there's this question that I have
of you know if we were just to imagine
you know independent of the difficulty
of implementation what will we want the
design to be I mean at some level just
like we have if we want sort of a bridge
right let's say that you design let's
say that you design a finite automata
through some programmatic way of
deriving it and minimizing you trip
products and then you want to put it
into an elevator you want to be able to
take that finite automaton put in a
system model have it be part of an
elevator sure right but there are many
many what I'm saying is that there are
many bridges for for finite automata out
to various parts of the system including
system obler fine fine but but I mean
also things like this ladder logic thing
I could imagine that since that's a a
known and obviously useful formalism
because it's been around for 50 years or
something you know one one could imagine
even having you know a rapper called
ladder logic in which you put various
things and where system model of ladder
logic or something can transform it to a
more general system model right then it
can integrate
with with lots of other parts you know
it's late so so for example if I had a
ladder logic thing maybe that
corresponds with some simple input and
so on just to a function yeah I mean
it's a state graph I mean it would
largely be modeled as a state graph
today
does it's trying to address the same
problem okay but we have no direct
representation of a state graph is that
true no I mean we have it in system
modeler okay but so as an example if I
wanted to take a system model and I want
to output the graph that corresponds to
the connection between its components
can I do that not as a graph object what
I did I think it does allow you to
retrieve the connections okay but why
not as a graph object because it has
ports which are not a feature of the
graph object in Mathematica as far as I
know well but maybe maybe okay I mean
they said it could be by having just an
external node on the port so to speak
right I mean internally we do for some
use cases we do actually create a graph
of these connections for example if you
create a system model with a bunch of
components and connect them together we
want to do layouting of these components
graphically on the diagram view and we
do that by creating the graph as a graph
object and or as a slightly modified
graph object in or from language and
then use that use the graph layering and
move from one language to compute the
positions so I don't think there is a
user-facing way to get that graph
because it's not directly useful well so
you say yeah I mean look if the group
goal was oh this thing actually turns
out to be a finite automata get me the
graph for the finite automaton then it's
plenty useful I mean
imagine advanced use cases where it
would be useful right but I mean the
thing I'm trying to get a sense of you
look the thing I'm trying to get a sense
of for all of this is you know I don't
understand the space very well of all
these different kinds of models of and
I'm I'm just trying to check that I mean
the models that I know about tend to not
be models that are in these Dae in right
world
right they tend to be homogeneous models
you know a model of of I don't know the
early universe it's not a dæ model it's
ready sure um but if you browse the
standard library you get a sense of the
scope of what it models well um yeah I
understand but I'm looking at these
names like system model and I'm trying
to understand what I mean I don't think
it's a terrible name but I'm just trying
to understand what we can grandfather
into that system model rapper I see okay
because I mean what we're talking about
here is the D experimental ization of
you know that core name and its features
right and I'm trying to understand
whether if in the future we have ladder
logic or something whether we can expect
this system model rapper to be something
where you say sister model of ladder
logic and have it all just work right I
mean we have something similar I mean
you can currently do create sister model
of a state space model or a transfer
function model in Mathematica and you
get a system model back why does it work
that way why doesn't it just system
model of the state space model that's
that's a fair point but create system
model also has other forms where you can
give it
things like equations so you can
literally write your equations work I
mean I can ask the same question there I
mean that would be a common way that
we've done this in other places I'm not
necessarily saying it's the right thing
here but usually a create function
creates a persistent thing whereas a
system model is not a persistent thing
just a thing hanging and hanging out a
memory right yeah until you save it well
how do you save it either by opening
system modeler or by doing export well
that's a doing export you know you know
doing export will be how you'd save
anything right right I mean it could
probably be shoehorned into the system
model function itself but much easier
much easier for for things at space
space model than differential equations
because there you have a bunch of ya
need a bunch of extra arguments to wrap
it all up I mean I've been honest I
don't think this is quite the right
design this create thing I think that
create is really something we try to do
to make persistent things I think rather
here it's a wrapper where it will be
ultimately system model of I don't know
system model equations of something or
something like this it's gonna make the
documentation of the system model page
even harder it's already very complex I
don't care we've we've got a pattern in
the system that create X creates a
persistent object this is not doing that
so its design is wrong okay now you know
and and we should not be experimental
eyes it and burn that in forever I mean
this is clearly look you know to my mind
it will be very useful and Roger I mean
you know we can talk about this some
more at a different time so just get a a
you know
yes it's pie-in-the-sky but a version of
what the whole thing would look like
with ladder logics and UML and so on
what would it look like if it was a
global view of these kind of sequential
kind of connected sequential thing you
know what did you call it compartment
all what did you call that we're mixing
metaphors so if you're trying to model a
PDE with an OD e it's usually called a
compartmentalized model okay fun but but
you had a name for this general class of
things of which UML and ladder logic are
two examples
and state graphs are another example
yeah so they they are I don't know if I
gave a name for that whole class of
things but they are typically modeling
this sometimes called discrete event
systems so what I'm saying is it will be
very very very useful to try to get sort
of a pie-in-the-sky global view of what
all this stuff would look like including
the agent based model stuff and so on
because I have no sense of whether those
are close to this or they're a different
branch altogether I mean I understand
that the full world models is like the
full world of math or the full world of
a lot of lots of programming or whatever
it's you know it's an infinite kind of
thing with lots of different tentacles
I'm just trying to understand what
things with the basic formalism that
we've developed for system model
what other things kind of match the
patterns of that formalism okay which
forms our modeling you know because what
you're doing here is you're creating
model then you're simulating that sounds
like a fairly general workflow for many
kinds of modeling right I'm making sense
but I'm trying to understand to what
extent that's true that's not the case
um yeah I mean so what
in general is that the mission the core
mission for system model is just that
model and simulate and then there's sort
of a set of workflows in and around that
you need to be able to import and export
to other modeling systems um because
often when you I can get going and talk
why no I can see that okay
but if you want to do analysis of it or
you want to do design so in control
design is an algorithmic procedure that
computes a system that derives a system
yes those things happen in the Wolfram
language cuz that's the Syst that's
that's a system designed for doing those
kinds of things okay when you said it
happens there it's like you have these
things where you have series and
parallel connections and things like
this is that part of this whole story or
right I'm saying is if you're not gonna
manually design it meaning like using
the GUI to wire things up to model
something mm-hm or you know God help you
you create a new domain so you need to
build the library before you can model
efficiently if you on the other hand you
want to do programmatic analysis of how
is this performing you know how's this
metric turning out you want to do a lot
of it if you want to marshal all that or
if you want to automate the design like
control design yeah or these generative
design models and things like this yeah
right that happens in the Wolfram
language that's the system that's
designed for those kinds of things
system modeler is not its kind or system
model is at some level it's like a big
version of nd solve sort of yeah I mean
and you and that's part of the loop that
you might need to do some kind of
parametric design but it is not the
design itself that's right yes yeah now
I mean yes I mean and and you know for
example it'll get more complicated with
neural networks right because I mean we
want to use
you know we want to use system model as
the system model mechanism as a
component in reinforcement learning
right for instance
so there's several scenarios for neural
net and machine learning one is that
this is even simpler one which is that
lets say that you model the world
instead of measuring the world modeling
the world is usually a lot cheaper than
measuring the world sure let that's the
fundamental property that makes model
based engineering be such a success it's
a lot cheaper no um
and you can do things that you can't
even do in real life
mm-hmm and in particular for machine
learning that gives you once you've
built one of those model that gives you
an infinite set of data to drive and
train those models exactly yes you know
getting data is super expensive for
machine learning which everybody's
learning now yeah yeah yeah right right
now you know I understand so and then
there is is just what you brought up to
but there's this this multiple kind of a
use cases for that is what I'm saying
reinforcement being one you know which
is I understand we're not ready to
experimental eyes this stuff however and
what I would really really love to see
as I say is this global road map of
where do we go from you know how do we
connect on the one hand finite state
machines I know but that can tell you
very near-term
and this is something been working for
for a long time and our users or
customers really want it it's it's key
is to conquer fluid dynamics I think ok
and we are almost there just almost
almost there and that sort of more or
less completes or support for Metallica
what do you mean
fluid dynamics with PD ease like solving
navier-stokes oh you mean PD fluid
mechanics as in some discrete sort of OD
it's it's useless
od you know so so for instance if you
want to model an HVAC system and you
need to model the fluids involved there
yeah okay so there is quite a lot of of
engineering systems that rely on that
you know - how to transport heat and how
to know if a model those those spills
flows okay you mean by prove my damage
you do not mean CFD or flow past an
aeroplane you mean okay I don't you know
I mean there's some overlap but exactly
characterizing what that overlap is
gonna take us little you know yeah well
anyway look it will be great to see a
roadmap of what the general modeling you
know I mean I've thought about a model
repository that would have you know
random models like you know diffusion
limited aggregation or something in it
but I don't quite understand how to make
that how to make the interface to those
models general enough that it's useful
to put them all in one big repository
yeah I think I mean this probably it
runs into another meaning but that we
should have but but getting a kind of a
core introduction to what is actually
there you know in the Metallica world if
you like which we've been part of
creating we were founding members of the
metallic Association I've been driving
that standard the but but part of the
the you know the benefit there is that
there's there's already effectively like
a marketplace of people developing these
libraries alright let's let's let's have
a separate meeting about this I agree I
mean I just really like to have some
which spans the finite state machines
through CFD agent-based models and so on
what is the map of the world of modeling
and how do we make sure to signal which
parts were biting off with what
functionality sure um but we're not
gonna do experimental Isis there were
some questions in our livestream here
from Carl some live streams are welcome
new course about system model
integration with
language seems useful but I don't know
where to start what is them so we're we
have a suite of courses that are being
revised and updated over to fall and
probably little beginning into next year
what's the title they're covering
modeling and they're covering analysis
and they're covering design so I can't
remember too deep actually I you know we
had a meeting this morning and I asked
for I didn't like what the titles
supposedly her um so it is important I
mean look I mean for somebody like me
who is not you know didn't grow up in
the engineering world okay I don't it
doesn't really you know system model as
such you know I it's the name is okay
but it doesn't really do much for me I
don't really understand what it is and
if you start saying modeling in general
I'm gonna think you know cosmology
modeling and things like that which
really is a different character than
what you're talking about
yeah sure is but their business their
all kinds of I mean look we have just to
bring that up and I've said this for 20
years in in meetings that we've had
mm-hmm um modeling means a lot of things
to different people you can build
optimization models that's something
that we haven't even talked about but we
now are getting very good at supporting
yeah um you know the new functionality
in 12 there points to how you do that
it's a fairly large scale right and we
can do stochastic modeling of various
lengths yeah okay and we support that
too quite well um this is well it's like
the weirdness of you know ladder logic
meets options pricing and well this yeah
because I mean there are somewhat
similar things right I mean they're
things where you can say you know I have
this particular you know financial
instrument that has this particular
logic about how it works and this flow
from you know you open this door and
then this thing closes and so on well
that that's that's kind of correct yes
but I mean there's a two
completely different branches of the
world but no but we've been bringing
them together so over the last I don't
know exactly I can room well for
instance we have extended and diesel and
diesel to both cover das
better and also cover what we call event
systems yes and those were largely
inspired by this mmm-hmm all right
anyway look separate meeting about this
topic it will be very interesting um ah
you know with an attempt to map out
because I mean I've also made some maps
of so I was thinking about a model
repository okay and it didn't really
work out I couldn't really understand
what to do because as I say these models
tend not to have well-defined modular
tentacles hanging out of them so to
speak right soma delica is a systematic
wait to build that in a way I understand
it has a way but I mean what using the
state graph formalism or whatever it is
that is in a sense if I'm understanding
correctly it's like you know how much
momentum flows into this thing how much
energy how much there's so much that and
it's a way of modularizing oh is that
not correct right were you mixing a few
metaphors but yes but I mean any given
component has a finite list of tentacles
is that a first statement that's a fair
statement that's a fair statement each
library is its own little modeling world
even if they are all expressed in medela
huh yeah I guess but they map to the
domain in question and we never really
tried to do this thing when we consider
doing it it would be like but the
beautiful thing yeah that you can cross
engineering disciplines sure I'm saying
it's not humane you know and it's
because if you build a real world system
chances are like if you take an
electrical motor is an electrical
component and mechanical components and
they're in one and the same so if you
have a purely electrical you know like
spice or something like that you can't
model the mechanical components if you
have something that's purely mechanical
modeling system like
understand to what extent of the
tentacles complete so to speak of some
particular thing like you know there's a
resistor but probably in the electrical
modeling part of it the fact that it is
you know one centimeter long and weighs
this amount doesn't is currently that
doesn't even enter but you'll be
surprised they did action model the
thermal properties yeah okay fair enough
fair enough
well okay look something for another day
sure okay but um yeah all right we
should try to do this within the next
let's say month we should try to at
least get a meeting to try and map this
out to try and see you know the goal is
you know is there a model repository is
it basically could it be done with my
dog actually I'm sorry I was asking that
question what is what happened to our
like a decade ago we talked about a
Wolfen language mapping for the full
Metallica language whatever happens with
that is that still a good idea now I
mean we we talked about them discard it
so right now it's it's it's it's that
would be a major project to do I
understand but it might be might be
worth understanding whether that project
if done was some um you know would give
us a general way to think about modeling
and modularity of modeling yeah there's
some hair with Metallica because the
Metallica language is it reminds you
kind of obscene us plus with objects and
you know I know I know I and all of that
no no no death is particularly
complicated per se but it gets pretty
hairy and details um okay so
is asking during this system model a
license to use the Waffen language
integration the answer is if you want to
author using GUI you need system modeler
if you have are if you have got a
component for example from the standard
library or you can structure
programmatically then you just need well
from language is that a fair statement
Roger yes so it's it's basically a
player plus you can in fact
programmatically create models right and
and so sometimes that's actually very
useful but let the most productive way
to create models most of the time is to
use GUI sort of drag-and-drop components
right which is what system modeler the
product does right yeah well the fact
that Karl is confused about this point
it means we are not communicating it
that well alright first orders I usually
call the features and Wolfram language
to system modeling features there is no
system modeler in there but yeah it gets
confusing right well so this should be
called system modeling Raj okay one last
point from our live stream Ethan is
commenting that um he wants to be able
to do tens of gigabytes of resource data
net models and so on
yes I I what we have now the wrong
people in this meeting to discuss that
that will be a good kick and Evan yes
yes can you can you make sure that that
gets on the subject on the on the agenda
for the next resource system meeting
yeah sure that that would be a good
thing to push again I think we're ready
to push that we are really over time but
let's see if we can't very quickly
dispatch synthetic geometry we may not
be able to do we have the relevant
people here for some synthetic geometry
yeah in here yeah okay so how much of
synthetic geometry is already DT
experiment alized none of it it was all
all came in in 1200 experimental eyes
even things like triangle Center okay so
every function is is
we're not gonna be able to get to that
today I mean which one of these has a
toll and whole story and probably mostly
these are fine but I think I want to
look at them one more time before we do
experimental eyes okay I'll put it in
the next we have to we have to wrap up
here
all right we're not we're not do
experimental izing that much sadly but
um I think it's useful to power the
field so to speak and see what's
happening um even if we don't succeed in
its the exponent wising I love a lot of
things um okay so um I think that's
probably it for today right ROG yep okay
we've got a bunch of backup noise from
somebody there um okay well thanks a lot
everybody thank you people on livestream
until the next time right thank you